I and the father are one.
Alhamdulillah. Right. You know why I can
say alhamdulillah? You can't. Yes. Yes.
Not as a Muslim, bro. You can't say
that.
Why is God?
[Music]
All right. What's going on, guys? Man,
we over here having conversations, as
you know, as we usually do. Uh, got a
friend out here, man. What's your name,
brother? my name brother uh Wasim King
Wasim King was in the building and so he
agreed to have the conversation with us
today man and so uh you know we just
going to get straight into we going to
talk about the scriptures and stuff like
that compare contrast now uh we was
talking a little bit last well you and
Sean were talking a little bit last
night about your views on the Bible and
and the Quran about Jesus and stuff like
that let me ask let me ask you what do
you think is the most uh I guess the
biggest difference between a Muslim and
a Christian and maybe a way that it can
be solved or reconciled.
Well, I really feel like everything
about religion is equal from the Bible
because the Bible is the first book of
God period. It's the Old Testament, the
New Testament,
the book of Psalms that's was revealed
to David, and the last and final book is
the Quran that's revealed through the
prophet Muhammad.
So, I really feel like it's no
difference in religion at all.
Okay. So, when you and you've read the
Bible before?
I read the Bible, but I read the Quran
twice, but I got the Torah. I'm reading
the Torah right now.
Good. So, and All right. So, we read
reading the Torah. Where are you at
exactly if you don't if you remember
anything? in Genesis.
Genesis chapter 3. Genesis. Okay. So,
you made the beginning. That's good. So,
well, man, I'm glad that you're actually
reading the the Torah cuz that's good.
Here, here's something with me like um
cuz I I read the Quran all the time. I
do. I read the Quran all the time. I
read my Bible all the time. And um and
it's really just because I want to be
able to have conversations with the
Muslims and understand and everything
like that. Uh now something important to
me is when a prophet is claiming to be a
prophet of God, Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob, right? Then he has to line up
with what the previous scriptures are
talking about. There hasn't been a
prophet that came that contradicted
uh the the the prophet beforehand. And
so with when I'm reading in the Quran, I
actually see a lot of discrepancies when
it comes to Muhammad's message in the
Quran and then like for example Jesus's
message in the Gospel or the message in
the Torah or the Psalms. I see a huge
difference. Now, in your experience,
have you seen any like anything that's
different theologically or you know
where it's like, man, that this is a
whole different different thing right
here? Well, you'll have to show me in
the Bible because like I read the Quran
front and back, but like I said,
I have to read the Bible front and back,
but I haven't seen no, you know, uh,
nothing like that, you know, in the
Quran.
Yeah.
But I was going to ask you what verses
in the surah that you was confused about
or that confused you? What s? What do
you remember?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, it's um, so
you got chapter, we can start with
chapter 9 verse verse 30
in the Quran.
Yeah. In the Quran. Chapter 9:30
and then uh I'll pull up a Bible verse
too.
All right. I'll pull up.
So you're talking about um the
repentance ataba.
Alaba. Yep. Alaba.
And this is this is a this is one of the
most powerful suras because this doesn't
start with bismah.
That's interesting.
This is the uh repentance surah right
here.
Uh you said 9:30.
Yep. chapter 9 verse 30.
And then so we'll we'll pull that up and
then compare it to a few things that
Jesus we'll do like we we'll go on the
same line of things and see what Jesus
says in the gospel.
So you want me to read it?
Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead.
All right.
The Jews say Ezra is the son of Allah
and the Christians say the Messiah is
the son of Allah. That is their
statement from their mouths. They
imitate the sin of those who disbelieve
before them. May Allah destroy them. How
are they deluded?
Deliluted. Right? So, it talks about how
um forget what the Jews are saying, but
the Christians cuz that's the important
part for me
as a as a Christians. Yes, we do say
that the Messiah is the son of God. Um
and and this is saying that those who
say that are imitating those who used to
say things that disbelieved in the past.
It's basically blasphemy.
Yes, it's blasphemy. And that you know
God's curses on God is against you if
you're saying that Jesus is the son of
God.
Now when we go into the gospel, we see
that G this is exactly what Jesus
taught.
Right? So like here in the gospel right
here for if you want to go ahead and
read that this is John 3:16 to 18.
Okay. For God so loved the world that he
gave his only son that whoever believes
in him should not perish but have
eternal life. For God did not send his
son into the world to condemn the world
but in order that the world might be
saved through him.
Whoever believes in him is not condemned
but whoever does not believe is
condemned already because he has not
believed in the name of the only son of
God.
Right? So like that's a direct contrast
between the two scriptures you have
where Jesus himself is saying that he is
the son of God who was sent into the
world to save the world and that whoever
rejects him as the son is condemned.
While here we have then 600 years later
the Quran coming and saying whoever says
that Jesus is the son of God is a
blasphemer. God is against that person.
They're deluded. They're a disbeliever.
You know what I'm saying? So this it's
not even just like a little small little
difference. This is theologically
on opposite of each other, right? Like
if I'm saying Jesus is the son of God,
in Allah's eyes, according to the Quran,
I'm a disbeliever, a blasphemer, and
he's against me. According to Jesus in
the gospel, when I say he's the son of
God, I'm saved. I'm redeemed
and not condemned.
I see what you're saying. So, um, let me
just tell you, let me break down what
that is, right? Let me ask you a
question. Have you ever read the Bible
front and back?
Yeah,
front and back.
Okay.
So,
cuz them is simple. So, all right. So,
to remind you, the Bible was here first.
Yeah.
The Quran is just a final revelation of
everything, right? That's what that's
what we think. That's what we believe.
So with um with that being said,
Jesus what we believe is that Jesus was
a prophet. You know what I'm saying? But
now that I'm reading the the Torah and
the in jail, bro, Jesus was special,
right? He was the only sinless
He was the only sinless uh
prophet, right? Yes.
So let me ask you a question. Do you
believe Jesus was a prophet?
Yeah. Alhamdulillah.
But just but not just a prophet. We we
believe that he was a prophet and more.
Like for example, him being the Messiah.
Notice how no prophet is the Messiah,
right? According to Islam, only Jesus is
identified as the Messiah.
Why is that? Why? What's so what's
special about? Because Jesus was
directly from God. That's God's spirit.
Wasn't nobody else God's spirit. God
created us from Adam and Eve. We're the
children of Adam.
The women is the the the you know we're
all the children of Adam of Adam.
So Jesus is not the children of Adam.
Jesus is is
the son of God.
He's the spirit of God literally that's
put in the human.
So that's why could nobody touch him.
So So now, bro, see this is why that's
why life was getting so excited talking
to you because your your honesty with
the text and the scriptures, your
understand it's it's real. So when you
have for example this um this
understanding that Jesus is the spirit
of God which the Quran says he's a
spirit from him right and his word right
directly from him that he sent down to
Mary
if we understand this about Jesus we we
understand that he's more than just a
human
he's more like Adam just human Moses
David Muhammad all of these dudes just
humans
he was I feel like Jesus wasn't human
Jesus was a spirit spirit in the human
flesh.
So that's why it's like when they say
they killed him, no, we don't believe
that they killed Jesus cuz how can why
would God let someone like us kill
something he created? Really though, a
spirit.
Well, see that that's that's Yeah, we
we'll get to that cuz that's a that's a
tough one. We we'll get to that in a
second.
The reason why I say that though, right,
is because when you think how powerful
God is, right, the Most High,
he knows everything. And you don't think
he knew them Romans wanted to kill
un unless there was a purpose.
But guess what though, right? When he
when But what what Muslims believe is
that when they when uh when Jesus was on
that cross
Yeah.
that God took his soul
Mhm.
his spirit back.
And made a look alike
and he confused the people. You know
why? Because people, why would somebody
try to uh blat was try to downsize Jesus
or make him seem like he's wrong or he's
lying, right? Peace be upon them.
Because that's wrong, bro. Cuz Jesus
never did nothing wrong. Them was people
in their hearts,
ill intentions.
So, so here's here's something
interesting. I I want to get to the
crucifixion in just a second. Uh but the
identity of Jesus, his nature is what
we're talking about, right? Being more
than human. So you as a Muslim, even you
can see that Jesus is more than human.
He's he's you you even went to the to
the point where it's like he's not human
at all. He's a he's the spirit of God
that indwelt in a human flesh. This is
something that's interesting because if
you read if we open the Bible, bro, we
open Man, I'm going to have to keep my
phone out actually. We open the Bible.
Watch this, dude.
Watch this. You're not far from what the
gospel teaches, man. So, if we go open
the Bible and we go to John 1 verse one
and then the Bible like I was telling uh
Sean yesterday,
Sean,
it's deep.
Y'all don't like like Zechariah.
Yeah.
And Mary and John and all of them
was around before Jesus even came into
the picture.
Yeah. Well, this this is different John
just to let you know this is a different
this is John the Apostle. But what
you're talking about is the
the
So, so look. So this what this is what
it says. Look, bro. In the beginning was
the word and the word was with God and
the word was God. He was in the
beginning with God. All things were made
through him and without him was not
anything made that was made. So
everything was created through the word.
The word was with God and also
identified as God himself. But then
watch when we skip down to the 14th
verse. It tells us what happened to the
word. And the word became flesh and
dwelt amongst us and we have seen his
glory, the glory as of the only son of
the father full of grace and truth. So
what you're saying when you say that the
spirit of God came in the flesh and
walked amongst us, taught us and took on
human flesh. Similarly, we have in John,
it's it said it has that about the word
though. It's the word of God, right?
That came and took on flesh and walked
amongst us, taught us, showed us the
grace of God and the mercies of God.
It's the word of God that did that. This
is why, bro, we say like the Bible
literally teaches us Jesus himself is
more than a prophet. He's more than
that. He's the word of God, a spirit
from God. Shares the same nature as God
that took on flesh and taught us
himself.
You're right. You You're right about
that, bro. As a Muslim, you're right
about that. Wow.
You're not wrong.
That's deep. That's deep that you're
saying that you know
that Jesus was a prophet, but he was the
only And that's it's okay to believe
that Jesus was more that you that he was
more than a prophet because he was
blessed like that. The way he was,
people will really think like that. And
it's okay because Jesus was the only
person who never sinned.
Mhm.
The only person, bro, who never sinned
with all of these people trying to kill
him.
Mhm.
Talk bad about him. Talk to him like he
lying about it.
Yeah.
They tried to do him like that. They
tried to kill him.
Now, this I want Now, now that we're on
this, I want I I think you'll be amazed
by this. Have you ever read the book of
Isaiah yet? Have you touched on that
yet? Prophet Isaiah in the Old
Testament. Okay.
I know who I heard of him.
Okay, bro. My God. It's a gym. It's a
gym impacted with uh prophecies about
Jesus, about the Messiah. So, I want to
show you something, bro, in Isaiah
because we're talking about the
crucifixion and stuff like that, right?
I want to show you this real quick.
Okay,
so here we have
an Isaiah,
man. Just you
you special, bro.
I'm not even going to lie.
Appreciate that. You know how many
Muslims we talk to, bro, and they like,
"Nah, nah. Jesus is barely, you know,
just a human. Ain't nothing really
special about him." Like, they really
they demean them like that, bro. I'm
telling you, we do all
I told you we going to have a good talk
tonight.
Nah, if they can't nobody say that about
Jesus,
they do it all the time.
Peace be upon him. You have to say peace
be upon Jesus name when you say it cuz
if you don't, that's like disrespect.
That's how real That's how powerful
Jesus was. cuz he was directly.
Think about it, bro. All of us had
parent, father, and a mother who had us.
Jesus never did,
right?
They put a spirit in them. Fire.
Come on, bro. Who you know what what
why wouldn't you why wouldn't that be
controversy, you know? Like that's for
sure off the bat.
Special right there.
Right now, now in in line of you what
you're talking about, the crucifixion,
right? on like why would God like God
wouldn't allow this to happen to
something he holds so dear to him so
special to him right and I basically
said unless he had a purpose of of
allowing it to happen now what we have
in Isaiah 53 and I'm going just I'm
going to give it to you I'm going to let
you I'm going to let you read I don't I
don't like I don't want to do the
explaining stuff I'm going to let you
read and I want you to tell me who it
sounds like to you I'm going to let you
read a little bit
okay
and then I'm going to stop you
ask you a question is this the old
testament
yeah it's the old testament Uh-huh. This
this is 700 years before Jesus is born.
Okay. So,
read from the first.
Yep. Yep. You can read from
Who has believed what he has heard from
us. And to whom he has the arm of the
Lord had been revealed. For he grew up
before him like a young plant and like a
root out of dry ground. He had no form
or majesty that we should look at him
and no beauty that we should desire him.
He was despised and rejected by men. a
man of sorrows and acquainted with grief
and as one from whom men hide their
faces. He was despised and we esteemed
him not. Surely he has borne our griefs
and carried our sorrows. Yet we esteemed
him stricken, smitten by God and
afflicted. But he was pierced for our
transgressions. He was crushed for our
inqu
iniquities.
Iniquities upon him was the chastisement
that brought us peace. And with his
wounds we are healed. All we like sheep
have gone astray. We have turned
everyone to his own way and the Lord has
laid on him the iniquity of of us all.
You can pause there. So with this
reading, bro, who does that sound like
to you?
You want to take another look? You can.
You look
to be honest. If you you really want me
to be honest, u
I really I
If you had to guess,
let me see. Yet we esteem him stricken,
smitten by God, and afflicted, but he
was pierced for our transgressions. Are
you trying Do you think that's Do you
believe that's Jesus?
I think that I sound like that Isaiah
was probably predicting Jesus.
Yeah, absolutely. And so this is 700
years before Jesus is born, bro. And 700
years before Jesus is born, God revealed
what's going to happen to the Messiah.
that he's going to be despised by his
own people,
rejected by his own people, that he's
not going to come in some magnificent
kingly way of glory, but he's coming
humbly as a servant, right? And how
they're not going to esteem him. They're
not going to think anything much of him,
right? And then it talks about how he
bore our griefs. He carried our sorrows.
And now he was pierced for our
transgressions. how the Lord laid on him
the sins of us all. This is 700 years
before it happens. Right? So when we
have this, right, we have this talking
about the Messiah that he's going to be
pierced for our transgressions, bruised
and crushed for our sins, and that it's
God's plan that this happens
and he's doing it for us.
And that's the whole purpose. The whole
purpose is because he's holy and he's
innocent and he's worthy enough to take
on the sins of the world to redeem
people like you and me to redeem his own
people even though they reject him.
That's the purpose.
So with that, bro, it's like you you
have this narrative and this isn't the
only place.
There's many places just like this that
talk about what's going to happen to
Jesus.
And God is already telling us this. So
when it finally happens in the gospel
and we see that the Jews reject him, we
see that they lie about him, we see that
they give him over to the Romans to be
crucified and we see him be crucified
and come back and raise from the dead
and says, "See, I'm alive again." This
has already been told
already. So then when Muhammad comes
later and says, "Oh, wait, no, no, no,
no, no. Actually, it didn't really
happen. Um, Allah just made it appear
like it would happen."
Well, look, let me tell you. So,
let me ask you a question. Do you know
who revealed the Bible to Moses?
It's God.
Do you know it's the angels? Angel
Gabriel?
No. No. No.
God spoke to him face to face
to Moses.
Directly. Mhm.
Okay. I didn't I didn't hear that one.
But I know who revealed the Quran to
Muhammad in that cave was the angel
Jabriel. You know that Muhammad was deaf
and dumb. He didn't even know how to
read, bro. Read or he was illiterate.
But the angel said read once. He
couldn't. He said it three, two, said it
again. Read. He He said, "I can't read."
The third time he said it in a way that
you that it it like way put fear in him.
So he was like
he was fearful the whole time, bro.
He started reading. That's how the Quran
came about. So, but do you do you think
that if if the angel Gabriel really came
to Muhammad that he would be giving a
different message than what the prophets
were given about the Messiah being the
redeemer of our sins, what will happen
to him, God sending his son into the
world. If if angel Gabriel, the angel
from God, the messenger from God, gives
a revelation to a prophet, will it
contradict the previous prophets?
It shouldn't know. It shouldn't. It
should not at all. So that's why I
wanted to show you some things because
when you really talking about this, you
have to break it down in science, bro.
You have to really be logical about
about certain things or you will confuse
yourself and confuse other people.
That's a good question. Do you think
Gabriel would do that? No.
No. The answer is no.
He can't. You know, like everything
that's written,
it is what it is.
It's no contradicting, no taking it out
because then that'll be us doing it.
Exactly.
If the word is the word, that's the
word. That's how I'm standing on that.
The Bible,
the Old Testament, the New Testament,
the uh it's only four books, the Quran.
So, a Muslim wouldn't be a believer if
he didn't believe in the Torah.
Yeah.
Uh uh you know, we we have to believe in
this, you know. So, let me just show
you. This is uh the Quran, Surah 19. I
don't know if you ever read the Surah
Miam. This is Yeah. This is so I'mma go
to cuz I just read something.
It's kuran.com.
No, this is uh uh Yeah, this is a app.
This is uh You don't have this app?
A app.
Oh, yeah. I have a different app.
Okay. So, look, let me read this to you
because this right here answer a lot of
questions, you know. And don't get me
wrong, bro. I understand why people like
talking about this because the Bible was
here way before the Quran, you know, but
one thing about the Quran, this Arabic,
you can't move that. That Hebrew, you
can't move that. You feel me? But that
English, you can always move English.
English not our is not our, you know,
that's why in order to really read this
Quran, you have to learn Arabic.
You feel me? So,
no, you have to. That's that's just how
it is. But the English is, you know, it
it's it'll help you understand it, but
it's different when you read in the
Arabic because it's never been tampered
with, you know. So, let me show you.
That's tough. If if if that's the case,
man,
you have to learn this, bro.
Cuz I have I have some examples where I
think that the Quran in the Arabic has
been tampered with a bit.
You have to show me show me a proof or a
sign.
I got you, brother. Please.
I'm going to show you everything I know.
I'm going try to give it to you.
All right. Let me show you the uh story
of Jesus right here in the Quran.
Are you trying to go to where the spirit
first comes to her? That's like verses
like 16.
You start like verse 16. That should be
where the spirit comes to her and tells
her that she's about to be pregnant.
You was You was right. 16.
Told you, man. I read this book, man. I
read the reminder. I be reading that
reminder like
oh it say oh hold up
it say uh
and mention oh Muhammad in the book the
story of Mary when she with withdrew
from her family to a place towards the
east
and she took in seclusion from them a
scream then we sent to her our angel and
he represented himself to her as a
wellproportioned man.
Now, let's pause here because it doesn't
say angel in the Arabic. In the Arabic,
it says rule spirit.
So, for some reason, I don't know why
the English translation, they try to put
their interpretations into this. That's
the word. You got to learn the Arabic
cuz ru
nine times out of 10, it means it deres
from from that, you know.
So, yeah. So, angel is is like a mal
malikica or something like that.
Malachi.
Yeah. something like that.
So this is R. So it's spirit, not angel.
So I don't know like they try to put
their their theology in there but they
shouldn't.
You talking about this Rouana?
Yeah. Exactly. Exactly.
Okay. So uh then it say well
proportioned man.
So the spirit the spirit came not an
angel. The spirit came in the form of a
of a wellproportioned man.
Okay. Then she said indeed I seek refuge
in the most merciful from you. So leave
me if you should be fearing of Allah.
He said, "I am only the messenger of
your Lord to give you news of a pure
boy."
Man, that's terrible. It don't even say
that. It doesn't say to give you news of
a pure boy. That's nowhere in the
Arabic. In the Arabic, it says to give
you a pure boy. The spirit came down.
See, it just say news of right here.
Oh, that's just parenthesis English. You
can't. Look, that's what I was trying to
tell you. You can't really translate
Arabic like that.
Well, you can, but it's it's always
going to be that. That's just like
Hebrew. And
see, now see, look, they do they do a
good job until they add parenthesis in
there. They That's unnecessary. So, it
it's without the parenthesis, it simply
says to give you a pure boy.
Uhhuh. That's just for like people who
don't know the Arabic to understand a
little bit better. Just like with
Arabic, like with Hebrew, cuz in in the
Torah, it's Hebrew on this side. I'm
pretty sure everything in that Hebrew is
it's like it's going to he in English is
going to change. It's going to change.
Well, it's so so to me it's pretty clear
that the spirit himself came down, took
on the form of a man and gave gave uh
gave Mary the pure boy. Not news of but
the spirit himself gave the boy to Mary.
Uh, and this right here,
I'm going to let you talk this one. Say,
it is not befitting for Allah to take a
son. Exalted is he when he decrees an
affair, he only says to it be, and it
is. See, there's there it is again. It
is not befitting for Allah to take on a
son,
to have a son. complete,
you know, complete objection and
rejection,
okay,
to the gospel message that Jesus is the
son of God.
Wait, can I say something? Can I just
say something? It's really not. You know
how
Let me tell you how, brother. Right.
Because
God didn't have sex with Mary.
No one's saying that.
But that's to have a child how he is. We
got to have sex.
That's us. That's not God though,
right? So he says it's not befitting for
for him to take a son at all
at all.
He said be fitting for him to take a son
Yeah. So he rejects he rejects in any
sense that he is a father to Jesus.
While Jesus is saying that salvation is
based on the son of God coming down into
the world and us believing in him,
trusting in him for our salvation,
giving his life for us, redeeming us, or
else we're condemned if we do not
believe in the name of the son of God.
That's what the gospel teaches. So look,
uh, this this is what like this type of
stuff is pulled up. This is second
Corinthians, brother. Um,
and this is important because the Bible
warns us. Even Jesus, Paul, the
apostles, they warned us about these
different teachings that would come up
later, that would arise later. And watch
how intricate this is, dude. Look. But I
am afraid that as the serpent deceived
Eve by his cunning, your thoughts will
be led astray from a sincere and pure
devotion to Christ. Why? For if someone
comes and proclaims another Jesus
other than the one that we proclaimed,
or if you receive a different spirit
from the one you received, or if you
accept a different gospel from the one
you accepted, I'm afraid you put up with
it readily enough.
So they're warning us that there's going
to be people, false teachers coming out
with a different gospel, with a
different Jesus, even from a different
spirit.
So like if we believe that that spirit
in the cave was angel Gabriel or
whatever that spirit was, there's no way
that that spirit that Muhammad
experienced, if it's from God, would
give a different gospel, would give a
different Jesus.
But that's what we see. what wherever
Muhammad got this from. And I do believe
he had an experience in that cave. I do.
I just don't believe that it was an
experience from God because it
contradicts
the Jesus we know from the gospel.
You know what I'm saying? That's huge
for me. When I read Moses, I see that
Jesus lines up with Moses. When I see
Isaiah, I see Isaiah lined up with
Moses. Ezekiel, Jeremiah, David. I see
all of these guys line up with each
other all the way pointing to the final
the final most important one, the
Messiah, Jesus.
Let me ask you a question. In the Bible,
does it talk about Muhammad coming?
No.
You sure?
I'm positive, brother. And and this is
that if it did, I would have to believe
that he's a prophet.
You really You Hold on. Let me show you
something.
Go ahead. We can go through all of it,
bro.
I seen something on YouTube and they
said that they talked about Muhammad
coming, bro.
Yeah, they they they think that all the
time. I can I can give you all the
verses where they say where they think
the Muhammad comes.
I can give it to you.
I never really read it or I never really
said it.
All right. So So you you got a few
places. So well this really deems from
uh a few verses. If we if we read if we
look at the first let's look at the
verse in the Quran first that says this.
Okay. So for the audience that don't
know where this comes from, let's go to
chapter 7 verse 157.
You've been doing your homework. He
I told you, bro.
I told you I'd do this, bro.
He said, "Still scriptures."
Yeah.
137.
7157. 157.
7157. And that's uh
Now, this is another reason, bro. This
right here is another reason why I
reject the Quran. You're going to see in
a second because it it makes the claim.
It makes the claim that Moses uh that
Muhammad is found in my scriptures. that
when I read my scriptures, I should see
Muhammad. I should be able to find his
description.
That's what it says. So,
you right.
That's what it says. So, go ahead.
Okay. So, you want me to read it?
Yep.
All right. You said uh
7157.
7157. Okay.
Uh those who follow the meah those who
follow the messenger, the unlettered
prophet whom they find written in what
they have of the Torah and the gospel,
who enjoys upon them what is right, and
forbid them what is wrong, and makes
lawful for them the good things, and
prohibits for them the evil, and
relieves them of their burden, and the
shackles which were upon upon them. So
they who have believed in him, honored
him, supported him, and followed the
light which was sent down with him. It
is those who would be successful. Is
that the verse?
That's the verse. So you see how in the
beginning it said that the unlettered
prophet
would we will find him in the Torah and
the gospel. The unlettered those who
follow the messenger,
the unlettered prophet
whom they find
they find written in what they have of
the Torah and the gospel.
Yep.
So enjoys upon them what is right and
forbids them what is wrong and makes
lawful for them.
So when I open the Torah and the gospel,
I should find the unlettered prophet in
there.
The unlettered prophet they're talking
about is Muhammad.
Is Muhammad.
Yeah. The the illiterate one, right? The
one who he can't read and write. That's
what that letter means.
Yeah, that's what that means. So, I
should be able to open up the Torah.
Yes.
Open up the the Gospel.
And find Muhammad in the scriptures.
There's another place that says this.
And you And guess what, brother?
You don't. Okay, we'll see. We'll see.
We'll see. So, look. Go.
They better be.
I know.
But if But look, for real.
No. No. Now, now here's the thing. Now,
let me ask you this real quick. Now, I
want you to go to chapter 61:6. Go to
chapter 61 in the Quran. Yep. Yep. All
right.
Chapter 61:6.
61 verse 6.
Now, as you're as you're pulling that
up, now let me I want to ask you a a
critical thinking question. Yep. I want
to ask you a critical thinking question.
If what the Quran says that
if it's if I can't find Muhammad in my
scriptures,
then that means that the Quran would be
false, right?
Well, I'm going to keep it real, bro.
Not ne Not necessarily.
Impossible. But but I'm not saying cuz I
can never say that the Quran's false cuz
it changed my life and millions of lives
just like the Bible did. But it's, you
know, you might be one of the first
person who found the uh error.
You might go down and but it's like have
nobody ever proved it because the Bible
is so thick, bro. You have to read every
every line. He's nowhere in there.
Every line. But look, if the if the
Quran says he's in the Bible,
and if he's not in the Bible, then the
Quran is making a false claim.
But I what I just read, I didn't read
that it said he was in the Bible.
It says in the Torah in the Gospel.
Okay, let's I'm going to go back to
that. But which one do you verse six?
Verse six. and mentioned when Jesus the
son of Mary said, "Oh children of
Israel, indeed I am the messenger of
Allah to you, confirming what came
before me of the Torah and bringing good
tidings of a messenger to come after
me."
So whose name is Ahmed, that was
Muhammad name, too.
So when he came to them with clear
evidences, they said this is obvious
magic.
Yeah. So it literally said that Jesus
said that a messenger is going to come
after him named Ahmed or Muhammad
whichever one interchangeable. So that
means that in the gospel I should see
Jesus mentioning Ahmed or Muhammad
coming.
You saying you had
there's nowhere in there not a single
word from Jesus mentions the coming of
another messenger named Ahmed. Now I'm
going to let you do this. Now go if you
go back to 7157 so you can see it. 7157
so that you can see it.
That is definitely it says that he's in
the Torah and the gospel.
7157, man. I read this front and back,
bro. You You on it, bro. You on your You
on your de glory be to God, man. We got
to The Bible says to study to show
ourselves approved. You know,
got to study.
So,
so I never Well, I read it, but uh it's
crazy how you know exactly. That's how I
know you searching. You really trying to
figure it out. That's good.
I'm telling you.
Nobody ever stop you, bro. Cuz you got
to take it serious. You feel me?
Don't never doubt the word. But look,
what' you say? 157.
157. Right. Right in the beginning of
it.
157.
Uh, right
here. Those who follow the messenger
messenger, the unlettered prophet
whom they find written
where
in what they have of the Torah and the
gospel.
Boom.
Who enjoys upon them what is right and
wrong.
Right. That's it though.
Okay. So, let me
All right. So, that's a good point.
So, if you want now, go ahead and pull
up Yep. Pull it up. They're going to
you're going to find articles that give
you different verses and I'm going to
show you how in none of those verses
talks about Muhammad.
Okay.
So it in the Quran it said Ahmed, right?
Yep. Said Ahmed.
Okay.
So I can tell you what they was what's
going to come up. What you might see is
Song of Solomon 5:16. What you might see
is John chapter 14:15 and 16 talk about
the spirit of truth coming. Uh what you
might see is Deuteronomy 18, the prophet
like Moses. You'll see these verses.
It's this imam called Muy Mink. You ever
heard of him?
Yep.
Mink.
I heard of him. He just came out with
his own translation of the uh the Quran.
For real?
Yeah.
It says that the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him prophesized in the Bible in
the Bible in the book of Deuteronomy.
See, told you the Deuteronomy 18,
right? Now, that's the Old Testament.
That's that's that's the Torah.
It's all the same though, brother.
Well, I have no problem cuz it says that
they should find him written in the
Torah, the
go find that one.
Yeah, exactly. So, did you see his name
in the Deuteronomy?
It's not it's not there. But what
they're saying is is that he's his he's
mentioned like his his description is
there.
Was the description mentioned to you?
No, it's not.
What was that? Now, let's go to that.
Let's go to that.
So, it's Deuteronomy 18.
Yeah.
Okay. verses 15 to 18.
A prophet with the Lord thy God raised
up unto thee from the midst of thee of
thy brethren like unto me until him ye
shall herk him.
All right, pause cuz that's a lot of
that's King that's tough King James. So,
did you understand what it said? Cuz
that's why I don't read it cuz I don't
speak that English. But let me just read
it in a little clear. Okay, so it says
uh it says you use mine. The Lord The
Lord your God. So this is both different
translations.
Yes. Yes. That's old English. That's
like our modern day English kind of, you
know.
All right. The Lord your God will raise
up for you a prophet like me among you
from your brothers.
[Music]
To him you shall listen.
All right. So pause. So it says that the
Lord God will raise up for you a prophet
like me. So this is Moses talking about
what God said to him. like me from among
you, from among your brothers. So he's
talking to the Israelites. So the
prophet that's going to be raised up is
an Israelite.
So that's not Muhammad. Muhammad's
Israelite according to to what they say.
They say he's he's from Ishmael, not
Israel, right? So the prophet that's
being raised up like Moses is supposed
to be an Israelite prophet. So that
automatically gets rid of Moses. I'm
sorry. Gets rid of Muhammad,
you know, but you you we can keep
reading it because that's what they
that's what they try to do. They try
what they try to say.
Just as you desired of the Lord your God
at Harib on the day of assembly when you
said, "Let me not hear again the voice
of the Lord my God, or see this great
fire anymore, lest I die." And the Lord
said to me, "They are right in what they
have spoken. I will raise up for them a
prophet like you from among their
brothers and I will put my words in his
mouth and he shall speak to them all
that I command him.
Yeah.
So you see
and whoever will not listen to my words
that he shall speak in my name, I myself
will require it of him. But the prophet
who presumes to speak a word in my name
that I have not commanded him to speak
or who speaks in the name of other gods,
that same prophet shall die.
Exactly. Right. That's it. So you see
how it's supposed to be from Israel. A
prophet like Moses is going to be raised
up in Israel. He's going to be an
Israelite. So when they say that that's
about Muhammad, that's a lie. You you
you can't see that that that's that's
talking about Muhammad
as no way, shape, or form. He's not an
Israelite. That's one of the
requirements. He has to be an Israelite,
you know. Has to be
I never I never Yeah, that's crazy.
Yeah. So, you mean is Muhammad mentioned
in the Bible?
You see a bunch of this stuff come up?
Jesus speaks about Muhammad.
All right. Boom. There we go. Let's get
Now we're getting somewhere, right?
Now we got to get somewhere with this.
That question was a critical question.
If Jesus, if Muhammad name wasn't in the
Bible,
do you think the Quran is real?
Correct.
Or do you think it's is is a lie?
Yeah. Exactly.
So my answer is I don't think it's a
lie. So we have to figure this out.
Exactly.
Because man, bro, you would be probably
the first person in history
to find a fault.
But I'm not. I I'm I'm I'm only Many
people before me have brought this out
and I know Muslims I know I know people
who was born Muslims who didn't came to
Christianity bro I'm going to keep it
real with you and they be trying to tell
me and I'm like nah I'm I'm going to
stick to you feel me to this thing but
alhamdulillah bro cuz we all together
bro at the end of the day bro we all
from God we was created to God we return
bro we all brothers bro no no matter
what bro
yeah we're brothers in humanity
we brothers bro that's how I'm I'm
standing on Christian, Muslims, if you a
real
I want you to become a brother in my
faith, man. Cuz that's what's important.
It's life or death with us right now.
You know what I'm saying?
Jesus predicts Muhammad.
The arrival of Muhammad. And I know
y'all got to go soon.
Are we?
Oh, he does. Oh, dang.
Okay,
we got to do this again, bro.
I'm I'm go to the moss, bro.
Yes, that's
bro. We could, bro. We could do this.
are concerned. Whatever is mentioned,
Old Testament, they have to believe
because of I'm telling you,
bro,
all of these people that you think is
sharp, I'm going to show you that
they're that they're deceivers and they
don't know nothing. I'm I promise you I
I I'm giving you my word,
right? Have I shown you anything that
was wrong yet so far? I guarantee you
everything that these people bring up,
I'm going to show you how it destroys
them.
Everything. I promise you.
Lord is my witness. Okay.
He like, "God, who is this dude?"
They call me Shake Logic, bro.
Shake Logic.
They call me Shake Logic.
I shall pray to my father to send you a
comforter who shall abide with you
forever.
So that comforter talking about mention
to me.
15 verse number 26.
The comforter will come whom my father
will send.
He will glorify me.
He misqued that verse but the gospel of
John 16 verse number 7.
Nevertheless, I tell you the truth. It
is expedient for you that I go away. For
if I go not away, the comforter shall
not come. For if I depart, shall I send
him.
So those are the verses I told you. When
they talk about Jesus, talking about
Muhammad coming, they quote John chapter
14:15 and 16. And so these are the
verses that we just saw. Now, let's
talk. You want to take a look at it real
quick? We got time. So, this is it, bro.
We'll we'll we'll work we'll work uh
we'll start with the first one that he
mentioned. John chapter 14 verse 16.
Now, it's funny that they stop at 16.
Now, you got to read in context or else
you just you this is terrible
interpretation. It's not how you read
the Bible. So John chapter 14, if you
love me, you will keep my commandments.
Verse 16, that's what they talking
about. And I will ask the father and he
will give you another helper. Uh the
other word is counselor or comforter.
What they're talking about to be with
you forever.
Now verse 16,
the comforter is going to be is going to
come and he's going to be with them
forever.
This ain't no human prophet. Number one,
number one, Jesus is talking to his
disciples.
So according to Jesus, the comforter is
going to come and be with his disciples.
Who do you believe that is?
That's the Holy Spirit. Jesus tells us
later, it's the Holy Spirit. So look
right here, verse 17, even the spirit of
truth.
the spirit, the spirit of truth, whom
the world cannot receive because it
neither sees him nor knows him, but you
know him for he dwells with you and will
be in you. Talking to the disciples and
for the rest of the believers. So the
comforter to come is the spirit of
truth. And you remember when we was
reading the Quran earlier, you said that
it was a misinterpretation with a word.
Yeah, the angel. Yeah, but they said
that they put it's the spirit.
So,
the spirit of God
said that they Who is that spirit in the
Quran that it said? Who was that?
It doesn't say who it is.
So, that's the that's the Quran. I mean,
that's the Bible saying something about
another spirit.
Well, this is this is the Holy Spirit.
The Holy Spirit,
right? So, look, look. So, if we go
down, Jesus tells us right here in verse
number 26,
right? So verse 26, it says, "But the
helper, the Holy Spirit, whom the father
will send in my name, he will teach you
all things and bring to you your bring
to your remembrance all that I have said
to you." So it's not a prophet.
So who hold on. So who is that?
That's God. That's the very own the
spirit of God. Brother,
who he coming in through?
No, he's he's just coming as a spirit.
So So
you don't believe that's the prophet
Muhammad?
No, it's not. He's not the Holy Spirit.
That sound like the prophet Muhammad.
How? He's not the Holy Spirit.
But he said, so if Jesus is saying this,
he said he will come to you in truth.
He's
and prophet Muhammad bring he said that
the Quran is the truth.
Wait, stop. So let's let's really think
about this. So let's think about the
attributes. Number one, he's the Holy
Spirit.
In the Quran, Muhammad is not the Holy
Spirit. The Holy Spirit came and helped
uh Jesus according to the Quran and
stuff like that and stuff like this.
Okay? The Holy Spirit, the spirit is the
very spirit of God. It's the spirit of
God, not a human. It's the spirit of God
that comes and gives messages and
revelations and, you know, uh, power to
do miracles and stuff like that. Okay?
So, it's not Muhammad.
Okay? That's number one. Number two, the
Holy Spirit
comes to the disciples.
Muhammad came 600 years after the
disciples.
It cannot be about Muhammad. Oh, so you
talking about he's not talking about the
future. He's talking about right now.
He talking about
Cuz it sound like he said the future.
He talking about is both. It's it's
presently and future. So presently, he's
talking to the immediate audience, which
is the disciples.
He's telling what's going to happen.
What's going to happen? And guess what?
They're included in what's going to
happen.
So they're not exempt. It's not like,
oh, I'm telling you about this Holy
Spirit that's going to come. Y'all not
going to experience him. No, he says
he's going to come to you. He's going to
come to you and to the believers that
come through your word. When y'all
spread the gospel around, other people
are also going to receive the Holy
Spirit. Right? But so the Holy Spirit
comes to the disciples first. Muhammad
never came to the disciples. It came 600
years after.
Muhammad, you know, the Quran came 1400
years ago.
Yeah. So it it's impossible to be about
Muhammad.
But guess what? It's not. You know what
I mean?
Because it's how well I feel like it's
not because the Just think about it,
bro. Like if if if like or I'm pretty
sure Moses may Allah be may God be
pleased with them
predicted Jesus.
Yes.
So if Moses predicted Jesus, Abraham
predicted another prophet. Well,
he didn't.
And or whoever. So if if Moses predicted
Jesus, why would Jesus not predict
Muhammad?
Because Muhammad is not a true prophet.
That's the point there. If Muhammad is
is if Muhammad is a true prophet, then
maybe Jesus might have talked about him
or something like that. Um or a true
messenger.
Nowhere he said no name or nothing in
the Bible at all. No,
not even uh
uh of of logic. This may this this can
be the prophet Muhammad from what he's
uh speaking through the Quran.
Well, that's what we're saying. If we're
let's let's take the name out of it. I'm
this is how generous generous I am. Even
though the Quran says Jesus mentions him
by name, I know that Jesus doesn't
mention him by name in the gospel, but
I'm willing to be like, you know what,
give me descriptions. If Jesus even
mentions the likeness of Muhammad, that
he like in the context he's talking
about him even though it's not by name,
I'll accept that because there's
prophecies about Jesus in the Old
Testament that doesn't mention him by
name. It doesn't, right? But it
describes him. It tells us what he's
going to do and the stuff he's going to
fulfill. And Jesus does that, right?
Born in Bethlehem, born of a virgin,
stuff like this, yada yada yada. And
Jesus fulfills those. I'm like, "Okay,
boom." So, we should have where Jesus at
least describes Muhammad,
but we don't. They go here like I told
just showed you Mut and Zach Knight was
quoting the verses I told you they was
going to quote.
And when we look at this, they don't
describe Muhammad.
It don't say comforter or nothing.
Well, no, it does. Like, look. So the
word in the Greek is paracletos which
they translate as comforter or helper or
counselor. So comforter
how I look at the comforter is the
that's my sign right there that that was
they was talking about Muhammad. That's
just logic because if it says comforter
that's what Jesus said in the uh Bible
or in the Quran.
No it doesn't say no not in the Quran.
I mean in the Bible he says that
in the Bible he says the comforter.
So and then in the Quran it says Ahmed
which doesn't mean comforter
or the comforter. It doesn't mean it
doesn't mean comforter. Comforter. It
means the praised one.
The praised one. Yeah.
So that's has two different meanings.
Yeah.
You know,
so you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
false prophet.
Yes. And these are reasons why because
he brings this Quran, this message
saying if you guys go into your
scriptures, you'll find me.
If you go into your scripture, my
research, you feel me? Yeah. If you go
So here's two things, and we can leave
it leave it at this. Two things, bro.
One is that this is the reason why I
believe that Muhammad's a false prophet.
One is that his message is a different
message than the previous prophets. He
Jesus teaches as we saw that salvation
comes from the son of God. God sending
his son into the world. That's how we're
redeemed. Right? If you don't believe in
the name of the son, you're condemned
already. That's what Jesus said.
Remember the first verse I showed you in
the Bible. But in the Quran, we saw
multiple verses. Those who say that
Jesus is the son of God are
disbelievers. They're blasphemers. God
is against them.
um it's not befitting for Allah to take
to himself a son. Right? So that's a
completely different message than what I
find in the gospel. That's number one.
Number two, Muhammad claims that we
would find him in our scriptures and we
don't. So if we don't then
let me ask you a question. Luke, you you
read the whole Bible. So Luke
16 through19
I was reading the uh verse to to act
right here yesterday.
How to get eternal life.
Yes. And Jesus a man came up to Jesus
and I want your understanding of this.
Sure.
You know because it all boils down to
logic bro.
You feel me? So
an understanding you know and this is in
the Bible bro. This is what Jesus peace
be upon him said. He said this man said,
"How can I get into uh eternal, you
know, life?"
Yeah.
He said, "Why are you asking me?
I'm not, you know,
can you go to the Yeah, I got you." And
the ruler came asked him,
"Good teacher, what must I do to inherit
eternal life?" And Jesus said to him,
"Why do you call me good? No one is good
except God alone." Now, that's not a
denial of him being good. It's not. No,
no, I'm not saying that. I know. I know
Jesus is good. Okay, good.
Jesus was the only sinless person.
Listen to what I'm saying. But listen to
his answer.
Yeah. It's a provoking question, a
thoughtprovoking question.
Why do you call me good? No one is good
except God alone.
So, if you're calling me good,
do you do you know what you're saying?
If you're calling me good, do you know
what you're saying about me? And are you
willing to accept what you're saying
about me? Cuz if you're saying that I'm
good in this context, then you're
understanding that I'm God. Are you
ready for that?
It Let me see it. Keep reading it.
So why do you call me good though?
But look, why do you call me good?
No one is good except God alone.
Mhm.
You know the commandments. Do not commit
adultery. Do not murder. Do not steal.
Do not bear false witness. Honor your
mother and father. And he said, "All
these things I have kept from my youth."
That's why he was that's why he was
sinless. So when Jesus when Jesus heard
this, he said to him, "One things you
still lack.
Sell all that you have and distribute it
to the poor and you will have treasure
in heaven and come follow me."
So there's one thing that he lacks in
order to get eternal life is giving up
his possessions and following Jesus.
So Jesus is putting himself on that
pedestal
except
No, he not. No, he not, bro. So then why
think about that?
Why is he telling them to follow him if
he's not putting himself on that
pedestal?
Uh that's just that's a good question to
ask, you know. But I'm reading I'm going
off of the scripture.
Yeah, the scripture.
If the guy says good teacher, why what
he said, good teacher,
why do you call me good?
You know what I'm saying? only the only
good is God alone. So Jesus taking
himself off a pedestal.
No, he's not. He's he's saying do cuz
he like he put God on that pedestal.
So look, it's it's like this, bro.
Don't praise me. Praise God.
But that's not what he said. That's not
what he does. He doesn't say don't. He
doesn't say don't call me good. He
doesn't say don't call me good.
Why do you
Why do you call me good? It's a
thoughtprovoking question, bro. No,
there's no denial.
Question. Basically, you said he's just
he's it's a question like why do you say
this?
Yes. And and but but not just a like a
like he's really wondering. It's a
thought. Jesus asked question. Look, a
lot of times Jesus ask questions to get
people to think. He did that all the
time. This is no exception. He's doing
it the same thing. Why do you call me
good?
There's none good but God alone.
Do you know what you're saying?
So, let me ask you something. Just think
about this, bro. Be logical right now.
Okay. You just said this. There's no He
asked Jesus. Jesus said this and he
said, "Why do you call me good?" There
is no good.
You're none good but God alone. So if
he's
So is that Jesus calling himself God?
Yeah. Exactly.
How?
Because he's good. He's perfect.
Why? But why would some Why would a
human say that's like you telling me
this, right? You imagine you Jesus right
now and I'm like Jesus, how can I You
like why do you call me good? There's no
good but God alone. I would be confused.
So I thought you were God.
No. No. So because he's not he's not he
doesn't have that understanding. You
were God though.
But he doesn't have that understanding.
The rich ruler doesn't have that
understanding yet.
Okay.
He don't he don't have that
understanding. Now here's another thing.
When it comes to when it comes to um he
he laid down the law, the ten
commandments. Jesus is telling them to
follow the ten commandments. But then he
says there's one thing you lack. sell
all your possessions and then come
follow me. Why is Jesus saying that
that's something that he lacks? What
what part of the Ten Commandments is the
young ruler uh missing by loving his
possessions and not following Jesus?
I can tell you there's a second one. You
shall have no other gods before me. You
shall not have idols, meaning things
that you put before God. Things that you
love before God. This man loved his
possessions more than he loved God. This
is why Jesus told him, "There's one
thing you lack. Out of the ten
commandments, there's one thing you
lack. You love your possessions and you
don't love me. But go and sell your
possessions and then come follow me."
Now, let me just think about it,
brother. Just because Jesus said that
doesn't mean he's saying he's God. He
already said, bro, only God is good.
Just think about it logically, brother.
When somebody say, "Come follow me, come
follow me, bro." That's like, "Come walk
with me." That's not saying, "Come
believe."
It's for It's for eternal life, man.
Alhamdulillah. But that's like
following. Think about it, bro. That's
like how we follow the ways of the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him. We
pray five times.
Does Muhammad give you eternal life?
No. God gives us eternal.
Okay. So, watch so watch this. Watch
what Jesus says.
You know what I mean?
Yeah. I got you.
Logic. That's no mean that you saying
come follow me doesn't mean like you
know
so watch what Jesus says.
He already said he God.
Watch what Jesus says, bro. Watch look
look.
He says this.
Uh they as
I love this too, bro. By the way, keep
it real cuz it's like bro cuz bro, I'm a
you know what I mean? I was a Christian,
bro. Straight up, bro. I got baptized
and everything, but I took my shahada
after, bro.
So, I really take heed to this type of
stuff, bro. I love these convers.
It's deep, bro. I don't take this as no
debate.
So, watch what Jesus says, bro. So,
verse 24, the the the Jews are asking
him. They say, "So the Jews gathered
around him and said to him, how long
will you keep us in suspense? If you are
the Christ, then tell us plainly. Tell
us straight up." Jesus answered them, "I
told you and you do not believe. The
works that I do in my father's name bear
witness about me, but you do not believe
me because you are not among my sheep.
My sheep hear my voice and I know them
and they follow me. What does this mean?
They follow me, right? His sheep follow
him. What does that mean? I give them
eternal life
and they will never perish. No one will
snatch them out of my hand.
My father who has given them to me is
greater than all.
That's deep, bro.
And no one is able to snatch them out of
my father's hand. Here's the kicker.
Because Hold on. Look. No, it's not
shark. It's not sherk. Let me tell you
why. Because when you think about it,
Jesus is the spirit of God. So
everything that Jesus said came directly
from the most high.
So Jesus speaking is God speaking.
Yes, bro.
Cuz he's God.
No, he's the spirit. Which means that
he's God. If he's the spirit of God,
bro.
Spirit, he's a he's like a basically
is your is your spirit not you?
Yeah.
Exactly. So the spirit but the spirit of
God is God, man.
Your spirit is you. The spirit of God is
God.
So if Jesus is the spirit of God, then
Jesus is God. That's why, bro, that's
why he
Okay, let me ask you a question. Jesus
God, who wrote the Who wrote the Old
Testament?
So So God
Jesus wrote the Old Testament. No, God
gave Jesus gave the revelation of the
Old Testament.
Wait,
that's Jesus back then, man.
No, that's not.
Yes,
Jesus didn't reveal the Old Testament.
I'm telling you, bro. I
Jesus revealed the Old Testament.
Jesus revealed the the law. Jesus was
there.
You telling me Jesus revealed Jesus.
I'm telling you, G. Look, remember when
I when I showed you how Jesus is the
word who was there in the beginning? I'm
going show you. I'm going show you. I'm
going to show you.
Jesus did not. Jesus revealed the New
Testament, brother.
Look, I got you. Look, it's 3 It's 3:09.
We here for a few more days.
This crazy, bro.
We Look, I'm going to show you it all in
10 minutes.
Nah, nah. We We got to We got
We got to sit down. Yeah, we here to the
27th. So, uh we definitely pick out
another day. And um
You got a computer?
Yeah.
Yeah, we we can go online. We do it
online, too. But we defin we definitely
going to link up with you.
Link up with me, bro.
So, look. So, look. I I want to say this
to said I wanted to end with this, bro.
Remember
the follow me where Jesus says follow
me. Yeah.
He said, "I give them eternal life."
Bro, I do that. Not just follow me, my
ways and my No, if you you follow me, I
give you eternal life.
I I see that. I see what you were saying
when you read that. You basically trying
to say that Jesus is giving Jesus is
doing God's duty. That's why you saying
it like that.
Exactly.
What I conceive of that is
Jesus, bro, is he's special. You know
what I'm saying? I will never how
special you you can't be so special that
you can say you give eternal life.
A real believer will never
a real believer will never disrespect
Jesus or no prophets. You know who are
you to say the prophet Muhammad was a
false prophet when nobody in the Quran
ever disrespected Jesus at all?
Well, peace be upon him. No one. You
can't be a Muslim if you disrespect
Jesus, bro. So, how can you say that the
prophet Muhammad is a false prophet?
Because let me tell you why. And and
this is this is what's interesting about
this. Okay. Um one, when I read the
scriptures and I and I judge by the
gospel, this is what the Quran says in
chapter 5:47. It says, "Let the people
of the gospel judge by what Allah has
revealed in it. And whoever doesn't
judge by what Allah has revealed in the
gospel," I'm talking about my people,
"Then we're among the wrongdoers." So I
have to judge according to my gospel.
And when I look at Muhammad and I line
him up with the gospel, I have to judge
that he's a false prophet because he
teaches a different Jesus, a different
message that contradicts what the gospel
says, you know? So it's not me coming at
him and like, oh, I just hate Muhammad
or, you know, I just dislike him or yada
yada yada. I'm looking at what my gospel
says. I'm looking at what Muhammad says
and it's based off of that. I have to I
conclude that he's a false prophet. Not
to any disrespect to him or anyone who
believes in him. It's just the
conclusion, you know, and and here's
another thing a layer with this.
So, you don't believe in a Quran being
the final.
So, you don't believe that that's the
last book of God?
I don't. And here's the reason why. One,
it gives us a different message. And
two, it makes claims that I have found
to be false. like Muhammad being in the
scriptures
because these things because of those
two things.
I gotta I gotta do some research and get
back at you on that
for sure. And I and I want to do it with
you. Like I I will
because I'm promise you, bro. Your mind
your brain going to change, bro. Cuz you
on the right track. Don't ever get me
wrong, but bro, you can't never doubt
God's word.
I don't got it.
But you are cuz you saying that the
Quran is false and that the prophet
Muhammad is false. You ever heard of the
Euphrates River?
Yeah.
So you know that's in the Bible, right?
Do you know that the prophet Muhammad
predicted that that well would dry up
and that'll be the final last hour?
But that's already been told about in
the scriptures already.
But the prophet Muhammad here to re
reveal
everything.
But he's only just copying it. You know
what I'm saying? The the scripture
already
Quran is basically the uh the uh final
revelation.
But if it look if a final revelation is
giving us a revelation, not something
that's already been revealed. So
Muhammad coming and saying, "Hey guys,
you know, God said that the Euphrates
River is going to be dried up." I'm
like, "Yeah, I know. It says that in the
Bible already." You know, that's not a
new revelation for me.
You know what I'm saying?
So when my my thing is is when he says
things that are not true, that are not
in the Bible, and that not just that
it's not in the Bible, but that it
contradicts what the Bible says, that's
my that's my issue with him. Okay. So
those are the things different Jesus,
different gospel message, right? And he
says false things like he's he's
mentioned in the scriptures. If he's not
mentioned in the scriptures and he has a
different message, then he's not a true
prophet.
Okay. All right, man.
Oh my god.
[Music]